Transcriber: Seben Gole
Gözden geçirme: Esra Çakmak
Dünyayı sen mi kurtaracaksın?
Sadeleşme ya da
sürdürülebilirlik alanında çaba gösteren,
değişim yaratmak isteyenlerin,
belki iyi niyetli ama
sık sık karşılarına gelen soru bu.
“Dünyayı sen mi kurtaracaksın,
sana mı kaldı?”
Ben bugün sizin karşınızda diyorum ki
ben dünyayı bardak bardak kullanacağım.
Kendisini bırakalım şimdi.
Neden bardak bardak kullanacağım?
Ben bir girişimciyim,
sadeleşme anlatıyorum,
sürdürülebilir yaşam anlatıyorum,
ama bir şeye öyle bir odaklandım ki
istiyorum ki karton bardak,
zaruri, zorunlu olmadıkça kullanılmasın.
Bu yüzden bardak bardak
kurtarmaya çalışıyorum,
ülkemi ve dünyayı.
Neden karton bardağa bu kadar taktım?
Karton bardak, karton, kağıt
geri dönüşmüyor mu?
Dönüşmüyor çünkü bunların
sıcak içecekleri tutabilmeleri için
içlerinde bir plastik kaplama olması lazım
ve bu plastik kaplama,
onu geri dönüştürülemez hâle sokuyor.
En azından hem ülkede, hem de dünyanın
birçok yerindeki tesiste.
O zaman ne yapıyoruz?
Kendi bardağımızı taşıyoruz.
Mekânda oturduğumuzda kupada içiyoruz,
termosumuzu götürüyoruz.
Böyle böyle,
eğer kahve içmeyi seven biriyseniz,
günde en azından bir tane, çıkar,
kahvemi içerim diyorsanız,
ayda otuz, yılda üç yüz altmış.
Yanınıza alın bir iki arkadaş.
Beraber gezip tozuyorsanız,
bin bardağın çöp olmasına ya da
çöpten kurtulmasına neden olabilirsiniz.
Tercih sizin.
İşte bu yüzden ben,
üç yılı aşkındır, durmadan, her yerde,
bütün anlattıklarımın yanında,
her sunumumun sonunda,
kahvem termosta diyorum.
Şimdi, kahvem termosta ne?
Nasıl işler? Oraya geleceğiz.
Ve asıl konumuz
kahvem termosta demek değil aslında
ama biraz bir geriye gidelim.
Neden ben bunu bu kadar
kendime dert edindim?
Çünkü bir konuda
farkındalık yaratmak istiyorsanız,
sizin hepinizin seçeceği
farklı şeyler olabilir ve olsun da lütfen,
önce bununla ilgili
bir derdinizin olması gerekiyor.
Sizi sıkmalı, canınızı sıkmalı, bir şey
olmalı, bir şey değişmeli dedirtmeli.
Bu bana özel sektörde oldu.
Beş yıl geriye gidelim.
Bir firmada çalışıyorum.
Kurumsal bir firma.
Kocaman karşılıklı iki binamız var.
Kocaman bir bahçemiz var,
yeşillikler içinde.
Mutfağımız var, filtre
kahve makinamız var, çay makinamız var.
Hem şirketin verdiği hem evden bizi temsil
ettiğini düşündüğümüz kupamız, fincanımız
her şey elimizde var
ve molalar veriliyor
ve görüyorum ki herkes o molalara
kahve fincanları yerine
karton bardaklarını
kahveyle, çayla doldurup iniyor.
Hani öyle bir durum ki
Türk kahvesini bile,
yine karton bardağa koyup götürüyorlar.
Kendilerince belki, pratiklik adına
bazı açıklamaları olabilir
ama bu beni tatmin etmiyor.
Üstelik işte diyorum ya
böyle bir beş yıl öncesi,
dünyada sıfır atık akımının
artık konuşulmaya başlandığı,
tek kullanımlık plastiklerin
veya diğer ürünlerin
artık canımızı sıkmaya başladığı,
burada bir yanlışlık var
demeye başladığımız dönem.
Ben kendi adıma çözümü buldum.
Ofisteyim kupamı da alıyorum bardağı.
Aşağıda bir tane kahve dükkanı var.
Bir kahve zincirinin bir tane şubesi var.
Koskoca, yanlış hatırlamıyorsam
beş yüz kişilik şirkette
kupasını alıp tek giden benim
ve bundan memnunum, çünkü kendi başıma
bir şeyleri deneyimliyorum,
olup olmadığını görüyorum.
Sonra işi bıraktım, normal,
gündüzleri de dışarı çıkmaya başladım
ve fark ettim ki
olay sadece bir yerde gerçekleşmiyor.
Sadece benim iş arkadaşlarım
değil bunu yapan.
Gidip arkadaşlarıyla, ailesiyle,
sevdikleriyle sosyalleşmek için mekânlarda
oturanlar da aynı şeyi yapıyor.
Arkalarında koskoca fincanlar, yıkama
sistemleri, her şey dururken
orada oturdukları,
bir yere gitmedikleri hâlde
yine karton bardakları kullanıyorlar.
Bir süre daha geçti.
Yine ben termosumu
bu sefer taşımaya devam ettim.
Bazen evde yaptım çıktım, bazen
aldım dışarıda doldurdum.
Aynı bu sabah buraya gelirken
yaptığım gibi
ve anladım ki bu çok kolay bir şey.
Çok kolay bir şey, çok basit bir şey.
O zaman bu, benim arkasında
güvenle durabileceğim bir şey.
Kendime o dönemden sonra misyon edindim.
Kahvem termosta diyeceğim böyle kulakta
kalıcı ve biraz ana bir konsept gibi
yani ben kahvem termosta dedim,
öbürü yeşil çayını koyar,
diğeri su taşımayı hatırlar.
Ama amacımız, tek kullanımlıklara
karşı bir duruş,
bunların karşısında durmak olur dedim
ve yola çıktım.
Bunu bir hareket olarak
duyurmaya başladım.
Şimdi tabii ki amacım ne?
İnsanlara termos taşımayı hatırlatmak
ki bence kendi çapımda
başarılı olduğumu düşünüyorum.
Mekânların bunu anlayışla karşılaması ve
karton bardağın nihayetinde azalması.
Şimdi buraya kadar güzel.
Burayı size niye anlattım?
Çünkü burada aslında hani çok klişe
gelecek ama geleceğimiz var.
Ben dünyayı kurtarmaya otuz
yaşımdan sonra başladım.
Daha önce farkında değildim.
Daha önce önüme gelen herhangi
bir şeyin sanki orada böyle
tesadüfen oluştuğunu düşünüyordum.
Kapıma kargoyla gelen bir ürünün
arkasında ne var diye düşünmüyordum.
Bu ceket benim için kumaştan
ve dikişten ibaretti.
Onu dokuyan ipliğin, elyafın, o elyafı
oluşturan şey sentenik mi bitkisel mi
bunların farkında değildim.
Şimdi dünya değişti, siz çok
daha farkındasınız.
Artık genç iklim aktivistlerimiz var.
O yüzden kendimce, belki otuzumdan sonra
kendi alanımda başardığım şeyde
beni farklı kılan ne?
Bunun buraya gelmesini kahvem termostanın
buraya gelmesini sağlayan şey ne
ondan biraz bahsetmek istedim sizlere.
Ben bir içerik üreticisiyim.
On yıldır, o anda ne meşhursa,
eskiden blog vardı, blogda sonra işte
Instagram, YouTube, podcastler,
aklınıza gelen her mecrada içerik
üretiyorum ve bunu çok seviyorum.
Tabii ki bu benim elimdeki bir güçtü ve
sadeleşme alanında, daha sade bir yaşam
veya sürdürülebilirlik alanında
birçok konuda bir şeyler anlatıyorum.
Ama ben odağımı kahve üzerinde
tutmaya karar verdim.
Neden? Çünkü kahve çok seviyorum
ve gerçekten her gün en az bir
bardak içiyorum ya da bir fincan içiyorum.
Bazen evde içiyorum,
bazen dışarıda içiyorum.
İki, iş hayatı, sosyal hayat,
ev, dışarısı, arkadaşlar,
insanların bu konudaki alışkanlıkları
hakkında iyi bir fikre sahibim
biliyorum yani soru geldiğinde
muallakta değilim.
Üç, odağımı bir yerde toplamak istiyorum.
Evet ben yılın üç yüz altmış beş günü
farklı mesajlar veriyorum belki ama
bunun yüzde yirmisini, otuzunu
bir yerde tutmak istiyorum.
Savaşını seç diye bir cümle vardır aslında
bütün sunumu bunun üzerinden kurmuştum
ama bir türlü hoşuma gitmedi.
Oradaki analoji yaptım, yaptım, yaptım.
Odağını seç diye değiştirelim bunu.
Odağımızı seçmeliyiz.
Zamanımız, enerjimiz kısıtlı, hayatta
başka sorumluluklarımız var.
O zaman bir odak belirlemeliyiz kendimize
ve orada istikrarlı olmalıyız.
Ya ben üç gün anlattım,
üç arkadaşıma önerdim
hiç kimse kabul etmedi.
Fark etmez. Sen bunu onlar için değil, bir
gelişim yapmak için,
bu yola inandığın için yapıyorsun.
Ben de hem kendi hesabımda,
hem buna bir hesap açarak,
günlerimi tek tek mekân gezerek,
mekânlara, kahve satan yerlere
tek tek mesaj atarak,
hatta algoritma lafı artık çok meşhur,
siz de biliyorsunuzdur.
Ben o kadar çok
kahve dükkanlarına yazmaya başladım ki
önüme düşen tek reklam
yeni kahve açılışları.
Ya da işte, yeni mekân açılışları, yeni
kahve aromaları falan olmaya başladı.
Bu da benim işime geldi.
Onlar benim karşıma geldikçe ben daha
çok yazmaya başladım
ve neyi nasıl yaparızın üzerinde durdum
çünkü sadece oturup ne kadar kötü ya
herkes de karton bardak kullanıyor.
Daha bugün önümde kaç kişi,
işte sabah buraya gelmeden,
kaç tane karton bardakla kahve aldı
demek yerine, olayı pozitifte tuttum.
Ben ne yapabilirim?
Çünkü negatifte durup,
neyin, neden kötü olduğunu anlatarak
sorunun bir parçası olmak değil de,
neyi nasıl yapabilirizi gösterip,
çözümün bir parçası olmak istedim.
Böylece ilham verebileceğimi düşündüm.
İnsanlara, şimdi burası
kopya çektiğimiz yer,
uygun, makul,
günlük hayatlarında yapabilecekleri
sayılarla oynayabileceğimiz,
günde bir bardak, ayda otuz,
yılda üç yüz altmış, üç kişi,
bin bardaktan fazla,
görselleştirmeler, grafikler,
mantığa, akla uygun şekilde
anlatılabilir bir şeydi.
Daha da önemlisi gerçekten benim derdim
olan bir konuyu seçtim.
Dedim ya size, gözlem yaptığım, bildiğim,
anladığım bir konu seçmeyi tercih ettim.
Bu şekilde ilk başladığım gün
aslında söylediğim şey,
kahvem termosta diyerek ben ne diyorum?
Size tam böyle sloganı da söyleyeyim.
Kahvem termosta,
çünkü içi plastik kaplı karton
bardaklar geri dönüşmüyor.
Ben bir hareket yaptım, ben bir jest
yaptım, bir adım öne çıktım.
Ey mekân ben sana termosumla geldim.
Hadi sen de bana sembolik bir indirim yap.
Hem çevre kazansın, hem bütçe kazansın.
Her taraftan win-win,
kazan-kazan-kazan bir formül.
Bunu yapan zincir bir marka zaten vardı
ve bana ilham olan o olmuştu.
Bana tuhaf gelen, ve siz de böyle
şeyleri arayın diye söylüyorum,
bu kadar basit bir çözümün, sadece bir
global marka tarafından sahiplenmesiydi.
Aslında bu çok lokal bir çözümdü.
Mahallenizde her zaman gittiğiniz kafenin,
alışık olduğunuz insanların,
oraya gittiğinizde,
birbirinizi etkileyebileceğiniz insanlarla
yayabileceğiniz bir hareketti.
O yüzden tek tek mahalle kafeleriyle
ilerledik
ve ilk akşam bir tane serde --
İşte özel sektörden geliyorum,
pazarlama olduğu için iki şey biliyorum.
Bir; pazarlama dediğin, tanıtım dediğin,
aynı şeyleri, farklı cümlelerle
tekrar tekrar söylemek.
Çünkü bugün beni ilk sıra daha iyi duyacak
ikinci sıra yarın belki
bana başka bir yerde rastlayacak,
belki üçüncü duyduğunda beni dinleyecek,
gerçekten aklına yatacak.
O yüzden aynı mesajı vermekten, ama biraz
daha yaratıcı olarak, sıkılmamalıyım
ve iki, insanların hareketi yaymasını
kolaylaştırmalıyım.
Ben ne yaptım? Şablonlar yarattım,
insanların hikâyelerine koyabilecekleri,
sadece üzerinde birkaç yazı yazıp
rahatlıkla dağıtabileceği şablonlar yaptım
ve bu şablonlardan bir tanesi
sayesinde, daha ilk akşamda,
bir tanesi Bayburt’ta olmak üzere,
dört tane mekân,
Türkiye’nin farklı yerinden kahvem
termosta diyeceğini söyledi
ve elbette önümde bir hedef vardı.
Bir yola çıkarken, çok katı olmamakla
beraber, en azından yolunuzu belirlemek,
ikinci adımınızın ne olacağını bilmek
için bir hedefe ihtiyacımız var.
Benim hedefim bir altı ayda falan
elli mekâna ulaşmaktı.
Bilmiyordum çünkü nasıl yayılır,
ne kadar hızlı olur,
gelen tepkiler ne olur diye.
İlk ay bitmeden elli mekâna ulaştık.
Daha sonra yüz mekân oldu.
Bu süreçte 2019 Ocak’ta başladı hareket.
Pandemi çok büyük, tabii ki sıkıntı oldu.
Yani mekânların
bırakın kahvem termosta demesini,
açık olmadığı zamanlar yaşadık.
Bu arada Birleşmiş Milletler
Kalkınma Programı’nin desteğini aldım.
Birçok gönüllü insan destek verdi ve
zaten ağızdan ağıza,
mantıklı olduğu için,
yapılabilir olduğu için yayıldı.
Şu anda Türkiye’nin yirmi üç ilinde, iki
yüzü aşkın kafe buna destek veriyor.
Şu anda liste güncelleme dönemindeyiz.
Umarım rakamlar daha da fazla olur
ve benim hayalim bu yola çıkarken
en uçtaki hayalim,
Türkiye’nin her ilinde
kahvem termosta diyen bir mekân olması.
Ben burayı seçtim.
Hani fili tuttuğun yerden anlatmak
diye bir şey vardır ya.
Ben kahveden anlatmayı seçtim
sürdürülebilir yaşamı.
Çok kentli bir şey olduğu için,
çok içimizden bir şey olduğu için
burada aranızda aklına,
çevreyi konuşuyorsak eğer,
çünkü önümüzdeki en
büyük sıkıntılardan biri bu,
suyu seçecek olan var,
gardırop seçecek olan var,
sürdürülebilir modayı,
tarımı seçecek olanlar var.
Siz de bir yerinden tutun ve istikrarlı
bir şekilde tekrar tekrar anlatın.
Ben hayalimi paylaştım,
sizinkini de duymak istiyorum.
Çok teşekkür ederim.
(Alkış)